Montana has become the first state to
ban Tick-Tock to make it really short
and sweet for you the law itself has no
teeth is probably unenforceable but more
importantly this is not the right way to
regulate social media let's go through
it in Parts The Tick Tock ban in Montana
would start January 1st 2024 if it is
not overturned between now and then
which it probably will be if it goes
into law on January 1st you would be
allowed to keep Tick Tock if you
downloaded it before January 1st and all
the law would do is prohibit Tick Tock
from being in the Apple or Android
Google Play stores while you are
physically in Montana you could use a
proxy a VPN or step outside of the state
of Montana download the app and then go
back into Montana Montana has said they
will not prosecute people for using the
app they are just going to ban the app
from the App Stores